du coup seigneur jésus la prière de tes
serviteurs qui inaugure aujourd'hui ce
lieu
laurent tatin déduction une réouverture
sous les meilleurs auspices après un an
de travaux le centre de séminaires port
royal situé à saint lambert a été
inaugurée fondée à l'origine en 1964 par
les moines bénédictins
le lieu a été béni par l'évêque de
versailles bénéat dieu bénis dieu dit du
bien de nos dieux fait du bien et au
fond les personnes et les lieux
j'allais dire toute la création est béni
par dieu et toute aberration est appelée
à bénir dieu le lieu a été créée par
cette communauté religieuse un prieuré
est toujours situé à côté de ce centre
très attaché aux valeurs de la religion
chrétienne
d'où la bénédiction c'est un beau geste
c'est le centre appartient à une
communauté religieuse les
assomptionnistes et pour marquer notre
appartenance à cette communauté on a
demandé à notre évêque monseigneur
aumônier de venir pour marquer cette
transformation du centre
voilà donc c'est un geste fort le centre
pas royal dispose d'une dizaine de
salles de réunion et d'une cinquantaine
de chambres
il sera prêt à accueillir de nouveaux
séminaristes dès le milieu du mois
d'août